yeah welcome to this video it's a
five-minute game on icc but it's not
played in the one minute at the
five-minute pool so don't be a shocked
by my rating here at the blitz rating
assess higher um gear viewer from the
from the channel challenge me and yeah
play of course maybe play one or two
games haven't negotiated that yet so we
got a Sicilian defense and i played this
Bishop b5 line and captured on c6 Rosso
limo um h3 is designed to make sure that
Nigerian and now I'm intending Bishop to
h6 and exchange yeah I think I'll do
that he probably will exactly just move
away yeah so short castle or or long
castle yeah probably long castle some
just leads to problems this is some
certainly the the simpler way to play
yeah I'd like to play a form but it's
not so so easy to accomplish
yeah maybe keep it keep it simple also
prevent any form of c4 yeah probably i'm
my long-term plan is to do something
like king yeah King to the side and then
prepare for let's see if I can maybe
provoke move like f6 so he doesn't mind
to exchange you know I don't mind as
well it is some not a brilliant position
after the exchanges they can try to to
play who I'm sorry long term um to play
against them the somewhat weak you
inside these parts are not a problem at
all at the moment they can they can be a
liability later black certainly am is
perfectly a righty em he can simply take
on g5 and that should do that
yeah well why he is thinking let me
briefly explain the difference this is a
blitz game in terms of icc lingo there
you can simply challenge other players
um but they also can always decline your
challenge so it's not so easy to get
them higher rated opponents you need to
fight your way up and very often people
only play three minute games and this
and this some setup I'm very much prefer
there was pool games of these Auto
pairing games because there you just
play the best players and it is well
let's say you have the chance to play
them in the normal Blitzer set up very
often you simply they simply decline
your your challenge and you don't have
the chance to to play them ok I want to
get rid of the night here and I think
you should go night to e6 this would be
much better than exchanging exchanging i
think is beneficial for me it didn't do
it ok i try to get an F form
Kim I mistake
and form yeah one thing is he's got the
points on dark squares which is
technically a good thing with the the
bishop on white square but one issue is
if you don't have a dark squared Bishop
anymore it's not easy to to actually
cover the pawns so it's a it can be a
case of technically good Bishop that
cannot help with the protection of the
pawns this is designed to capture on a
four with the rook I know I can take or
yeah probably anything I should take and
here now I'm now I'm attacking me five
and here cannot really care coverage you
can play rook e8 and then I take on b5
and get a 5 yeah this is now quite
tricky he takes on a four I think I can
take a five and have an intermediate tag
on the d7 Bishop with check so yeah and
now i can take here and take a 5 to 1
upon in the process and he's tied to the
defense of of this pawn okay I want to
prevent King to f6 or King to e6 so with
this rook move from he only has his own
work to cover the porn become
move pawn save it I'll just go with the
King to 22 and make sure that the pawn
is protected so I proved I can of your
doll I just wait a second I don't mind
the exchange here of course but
something better now probably this is
all right good enough let's let's put it
this way and now let's fix this on a
light square my DNA is king to d2 and
then c3 and deform so that I have a real
extra porn a bath bomb yeah
don't know maybe I should be roots of
the denied iam
check
I want to play this one I hope this is
all right now Bishop e3 is a nice trick
but I can take g3 Bishop a tree takes g2
and promotes but then I can I would have
been able to take g3 anyway so this is
two parts now how to win this easily
maybe I'm reroute this this night to e3
when to defy the Air Force and is
another way to to play black resigns
yeah okay two points is a bit too much
yeah the enter this end game was really
a bit a bit tricky but probably if you
look at this position here a move like
Bishop e6 should be perfectly all right
just just two is six covering the c-4
square it is maybe maybe a very slight
advantage for white I don't think it's a
it's very serious but dumb Mike and can
try on its it simply slightly better
structure yeah thanks for watching this
game